Speaker 1: Let's talk a little bit
about new claims relating to the 2020
presidential election, and I know many of
you will say, David, it's 15 months. That
was 15 months ago. How could? We're still getting
new claims and the answer is that yes, we are.
And this one is particularly important
because it really shows the naivete
of many of the believers in these 2020 Big
Lie type stories. We're going to look at a
very interesting but also kind of vomit esque clip
from apparently Republican Congressman Matt Gaetz,
who is being investigated for all sorts of serious
crimes. Matt Gaetz, I guess, has a podcast on
right wing platform Rumble, which The David Pakman
Show now also is on. We're put it, you know,
throwing our hat in the ring, seeing if we
can deprogrammed. Some people over on Rumble
and Matt Gaetz interviewed Marjorie Taylor
Greene, fellow radical Republican congresswoman.
Now Marjorie Taylor Greene has previously
made some statements about her husband's
2020 vote. But in this clip, she straight up says
that her husband's vote was stolen. It was stolen
back in 2020 and that he showed up and they said,
Mr. Greene, Sir, you've already voted, and let's
just listen to her story. This will be new, I
assume, to most of you, because she's never told
the story in this particular way ever before, even
though it's been 15 months since the election.
Speaker 2: We will get criticism
after this episode airs.
Speaker 3: I could care less.
Speaker 1: I haven't, even by the way, remember,
remember, it's I couldn't care less. And I don't
know. Some of you wrote to me and you said no.
There is a longer version of the phrase in which
it was. I could care less sarcastically, OK.
The phrase now is I couldn't care less, and I
know I must point that out. It's very important.
Speaker 2: Finish the sentence,
but I totally get the energy.
We will get criticism because we are making famous
the people in Georgia who I think are able to
perpetrate fraud based on their anonymity.
Speaker 3: They should be famous.
They should be famous.
Speaker 2: And I honestly think in all
Speaker 3: of you know, my
husband's vote was stolen.
Speaker 2: Tell me about it.
Speaker 3: So Perry goes to go vote in the general
election and he goes in person because we don't
do absentee ballot. So we never requested one. We
will not take part in it. He goes in-person. He's
really excited to go, vote for me for Congress and
vote for President Trump and vote Republican. He
shows up and they say, Mr. Green, you've already
voted by absentee ballot. He was shocked.
This was in November for the 2020 election.
He goes, No, I have not voted absentee ballot.
I never even ordered one. And they said, Yeah,
we have it right here. And it showed on the screen
that he'd already voted absentee ballot. He had to
go through the this 45 minute process, signing all
these waivers, proving, you know, this, you know,
a statement saying he had not voted before
they let him go, cast his vote electronically
and actually vote in person. So but guess what?
There was no. No one told him that they would find
the fake ballot right, that supposedly someone
cast in his name by absentee, and no one said,
we can get rid of that and tear it up.
Speaker 1: Now, there is no actual proof
that anybody did submit that we don't even
know, assuming what she's saying is true.
We don't know where it was merely a clerical
error. We just don't know. And the other
important thing is that the story that she
told was different. Back in November of 2020,
the Atlanta Journal Constitution covered this in
an article called Green falsely claims husband's
voting record reveals a scam. She tweeted at the
time Now we can't go back and look at the original
tweet because she's been banned from Twitter for
spreading weaponized COVID disinformation. But
at the time she wrote Georgia election scam. My
husband never requested an absentee ballot, but
when he went to vote, they told him he had hoped
they had already received his absentee ballot,
but he never requested an absentee ballot, nor
did he send one in. Green posted a screenshot
of Peregrine's voter information showing her
husband voted early on October 23rd and the
vote was accepted. The screen also shows a second
ballot requested and received the same day was
canceled. What really happened to the other
ballot? Now understand that there now we have.
Now we have a story of two early ballots,
which she didn't just mention to Matt Gates.
Robert Brady, the chief clerk of elections
from Floyd County, said nothing happened.
The ballot was canceled according to procedure,
according to this, he signed an affidavit on
the 23rd of October and was allowed to vote. He
only voted once. Trump questioned this as well.
Also relevant to the Marjorie Taylor
Greene thing, Greene began tweeting
about her husband's ballot Sunday. By Monday,
it had been retweeted more than 7000 times.
Brady, the Floyd election official, said he
couldn't tell from the information available
Monday if Monday if Peregrine had actually been
sent a ballot or if it was a data entry error.
But either way, the poll worker followed the
correct procedure by canceling the application,
asking the voter to sign an affidavit and then
providing a fresh ballot. That in-person ballot
was accepted. Once this shows him as having cast
the ballot, it wouldn't matter if we got 25 more.
We are not going to take any more of
them because we know there aren't more
ballots in place, so it's all super confusing.
And she also said that this happened in November,
but it's unclear, like all of this
might have happened in October,
in which case why did she say it happened in
November? It's all bizarre, it's all confusing.
And this is actually a very Trumpian strategy,
which is sort of like, tell a version, tell every
version of any particular story. My husband's vote
was stolen. He got two ballots. Now he got one.
We went in in person in November. Well, the
record shows you went in in October. Well,
that doesn't matter. It was definitely stolen,
and we've got to fix it. And of course,
at the end of the day, it's all more or less a
red herring because regardless of what happened,
only one of Peregrine's potentially multiple votes
was counted, meaning the system worked correctly
number two. It wouldn't have made a difference in
the state of Georgia and number three, even if it
had made a difference in the state of Georgia,
it wouldn't have made a difference in the United
States. That doesn't mean we don't care about
supposed irregularities. And again, this is only
a supposed irregularity because Marjorie Taylor
Greene story is so convoluted. We don't even
really know which version she alleges to be true
doesn't mean we don't care about irregularities.
But when we say are elections more or less
working when it comes to the logistics of voting,
one question would be would the alleged
irregularities that have been actually reported
in a proper way, not Trump vaguely mentioning they
lost 100000 votes. There's no evidence for that.
But are the actual reported irregularities even
a fraction of the margin in any state? The answer
is, of course, no. And that's what we really mean
when we say, can we generally speaking trust the
results now separately? And this is why there's
a sort of projection from the right on this.
Separately, there's the question of did
everybody who intended to vote actually
vote? When we talk about the voter
suppression techniques limiting voting hours,
purging people from voter rolls, involuntary
stuff like that, and that's a different story. But
it's important to understand that while the right
claims, the problem is stuff like this, well, they
just deleted 100000 votes. That doesn't appear to
be the problem. The real issue are the concerted
voter suppression tactics that we've been covering
for what, close to fifteen years or something like
that. So yet another story from Marjorie Taylor
Greene that just doesn't really quite make sense.